what's your reaction meant to people who
have suggested that you should try to
change your position
I'm not going to their team if anything
you know who ever liked me a quarterback
that's what I'm going just a couple of
years ago Lamar Jackson with the talk
about changing positions Ozzie Newsome
the former GM of the Baltimore Ravens
saying that he clearly is a quarterback
and the talk came up of scouts asking
him to work out a different position and
there's a very easy procedure to do it
any scout can say we'd like you to work
out your position I say is no right the
question did come up and that leads into
the first a lot of people in this room
who bagged on me about me saying Lamar
Jackson when I first came out and said I
think he's one of the best quarterbacks
in the draft I've looked over here a few
already they named names no I'm not
gonna do my name's but you can't pull
the pack Nate no I totally can but yeah
it bothers me it does because I felt
like I had a lot of people who were
sarcastic and kind of snarky to me not
only here at the combine but when we
went to the owners meeting Oh Lamar
Jackson huh you really think use the top
rather the best quarterbacks from the
draft hey yeah I do screw you did you
see that NFL MVP scruff that's something
I just told it really is far less
meaningful and impactful if you're not
willing to I know I'm not I'm not well I
know I do but I can't privately hold a
grudge I can't well I'm gonna let them
know to their face later today all right
well I'll have my phone on recording the
moment
play it to our on PFD live all right the
reason we're having this discussion is
we're gonna do some combine props and
what is the over-under on the number of
quarterbacks that will get asked if
they'll work out in another position the
dividing line is 0.5 do you think it'll
be over or under we've already heard
Jalen Hertz come out and preemptively
say he's not working out at any other
positions how many quarterbacks will be
asked to do it over under 0.5 well I got
to think there's gonna be more than
points ISM going over there I do I mean
it doesn't matter what Jalen Hurd says
right now I mean he's going to be asked
still to play other positions you know
I'm he's a guy
I'm interested in evaluating just first
off right away you know I know he's
improved as a pastor I don't nuts gonna
sit here and tell you that I definitely
sit here and look at him as an NFL
quarterback right now just from TV
scouting but I think there's got to be
some other guys that are you know good
athletes we see this every year who
we're gonna be toyed with two tight end
or slot slot
you know receiver something like that
yeah and is there anybody else that
jumps to mind I can't think of it yeah
jumps off the top of my head we go from
quarterback and I feel like what we've
seen from young quarterbacks in recent
years as NFL coaches become more willing
to adapt their offense where I have fit
what the guy does at college they're
willing to accept that their quarterback
yeah we've gotten away from that well
you have to be a pro-style quarterback
you have to run our system if we like
you we're gonna do what you do well yes
and we're not gonna try to force you to
be something you're not
yeah no I think that's you're exactly
right we finally in the NFL have stopped
trying to you know you know squish a a
round peg into a square hole as far as
making everybody into Peyton Manning and
Tom Brady no not everybody's like that
you know another guy they're just
thinking of that conference you know the
kid from Navy Malcolm Perry was a
quarterback
I mean he's he'd read slot receiver all
over the place to me I mean that's what
he is I think he's another great career
so he would be another guy that jumps
out to me I saw him in person and gets
Notre Dame he can fly and I think he
does have a career as that slot Julian
Edelman type guy last year the fastest
40-yard dash the Scouting Combine came
from undrafted safeties edrick woods the
four point two nine seconds did not even
get him selected the over-under on the
fastest 40-yard dash at this year's
Scouting Combine is four point two nine
seconds are you over or are you what do
you think I mean it sounds like there's
bugs you know henry rugs is the one who
already has run a 4-3-3 at the alabama
junior probe right now that's not the
same so it's not a strict right but I
think if anybody's got a chance it's him
and you know it's all about how quickly
for ED when we're talking about that
kind of speed it comes down to how
quickly you get out of the ball no doubt
it's it's it's a it's a measured race it
really is I mean to the point where
these kids are gonna have they're gonna
know how many steps they've run in that
race and when they finish the line
they're gonna go oh I took an extra step
that's gonna be a little slow or
one less step that might be faster
whatever it may be but I'm still I'm
gonna go over you know for tuned not for
two S's flying so I gotta see it to
believe it we don't have a lot of people
crack for twos every year and that's for
special special speed and as much as I
see Jerry Judy and how flat you know how
fast he is and Henry rugs and all that
I'm still going over yeah I I'm saying
under just because I wanted to yeah you
want the right one event every year that
captures some fascination and and look
for certain positions there is a
correlation right wide receiver he be
definitely correlate right
I remember when remember Bruce Campbell
sure and a fat a really fast forward a
big deal he's an offensive lineman
it was an amazing 40-yard dash right but
one's a lineman ever run in 40 yo right
at most ten yards is all that matters
for an offensive line exactly and I
we're talking about that yesterday all
right let's move on to the bench press
last year Giants defensive lineman
Dexter Lawrence did the most bench press
reps of anyone who was drafted 36 times
with 225 with long arms - he had long
and that's the key and that's Warren
Sapp remember Warren Sapp always said
because he had a horrible performance
yeah at the bench press at the Scouting
Combine because he has long arms right
the reason Loren Warren Sapp had a bad
showing on the bench press is because he
didn't bench press before that knowing
him yeah yeah but it didn't matter
he'd be the first guy's you know the
first guy I bring up in the gym to
people sometimes who you know you know
the guy in the Jimmy you see he's like
I'm on my 900 set a bench and I've done
curls my legs are this skinny but my
arms are this big and Warren Sapp would
be the perfect guy to go if it means
nothing I used to see him not be able to
bench 225 pounds and then go out outside
and throw 330 pounders around like they
were rag dolls now how many times can
you benchpress 125 I could do 125 I know
at least 20 times what least of
ghostrider 35 yes 125 is nothing 125 125
is nothing coming up later in the week
there's a bench press right over here at
the NFL combine
we can take one of the plates off I've
weight lifted wasted for I know it 125
we will be going there it's all right
wait a minute you're gonna need the bar
the bars 45 still why the bars 40 you
need to make the damn thing 50 you're
getting the bar a 35-pound plate on each
side you went to Texas and a five-pound
point on each side I'll do it I'll do 20
reps of 125 oh my gosh get ready for the
greatest social media event we've seen
in recent history 125 you're not gonna
take 20 and who do you think you are I
don't know what to the I don't know I
will surprise you remember Steve McNair
Steve McNair was another one of those
who would never lift weights and he was
as strong as a bull
right no Country Strong yeah and that
like it sounds like Warren Sapp yeah he
was saying let me down for 20 okay I'm
getting little nervous I do it but but
your dad did 20 pull-ups boy yeah okay
but my dad's a little different than you
sorry you know what if you went to
brains I'd go I'd take Mike floor if it
goes to muscles I'm going phil simms
sorry give me give me the right of first
refusal to delete it if I don't get one
I don't like that how many pushups can
you do long arms I don't know I don't
know I can do more than 20 though I
don't know 50 in a city I could do more
in one yeah in one sitting yes now I
think I could you think I could do in
one sitting
mmm one one set one set yeah I don't
know 40 would be pushing it that I can
do 40 right now right now 40 right now
no I don't want to see it right now
right now but we'll do it later I'm
gonna hold this trick to none of this
like you know like hold it I don't mean
I don't want to sound military I don't
want to see like oh 1 2 like you just
barely bent your elbows and we're gonna
count one you're gonna get down to like
close to the ground bring it all right
we'll get better steak dinner on it that
you'll never give up what am i two in
the hole in the Signum I can't remember
we did double or nothing at some point I
can't remember what it was lost all
right let's see what else we have we got
more here over under on the anonymous
reports questioning chase Young's
competitiveness after choosing not to
workout at the combine 0.5 I hope it's
under I'm so sick of that and I hope
it's played out and I've tried to shame
everyone in the media who tries to pull
this crap when a guy who has the hay in
the barn he's clearly a top pick and he
makes a strategic decision not to work
out yeah pulling me to get upset because
we're not gonna we want to be
entertained entertain us no no you've
got his job his job I you right and
College right that's it right now his
job is to keep myself healthy and get
himself drafted as high as possible he
has no need to work out and I will but I
will go after anybody not physically
okay I may be feeling pretty tough after
I bench one 25 20 times I will go after
anyone who tries to question his
competitiveness it's stupid this isn't a
competition right no I'm with you there
now how many people do you think
actually will question are you going in
the over of the under there all right
well all it takes is one I know right
what does it take to be someone in the
media to there's so many people in the
media somebody will say yeah I mean this
somebody will confuse their
disappointment that they're not going to
get to see this guy work out like you
were standing up boy I'd love to see him
run I'd love to see him do this and
they're gonna make well do we do we know
that he's truly competitive if he's not
willing to show up and show what he can
do him it's the same old tired crap that
we here ever it is it's the same old
time we're gonna hear it I just I've
typically tuned it out so it doesn't
irritate me because you know and I think
this is a function this isn't some great
enlightenment as my son has gotten older
and older and he's older now than these
guys who are coming through here yeah
start to identify with you know like
you're taking you know leggy I've got a
drooping like you know when you when
your child is a certain age you kind of
feel this weirder sense of
responsibility of other people that it's
weird like any five year right now yeah
I see a 13 or nine-year-old oh okay I
know with this case you're gonna feel
the same thing as your kids get older
and I think that has a lot to do with it
I do too know as that may sound
all right over/under on the number of
head coaches that don't come to the
Scouting Combine next year at all 2.5
that's a little high
oh I think that is a little high I mean
we don't have any head coaches not here
dish we had shape leaving early leaving
or trying to install a new office right
but they're gonna be here right here
yeah I think that I'm going with the
under there I mean I don't expect this
to be I expect the common trend where
who do we hear the Broncos and the Rams
right are sending the whole staff I
think that is going to continue to be a
trend here as we go not sending any
assistant right Rams are restricting
some of who's some guys right there in
the lab working on the shirt
reconstituted Shaun McVeigh I think this
will become a thing as we go into the
future here in the NFL you know I think
it's you know one if I'm a head coach
right I don't know necessarily if I want
my coaches just you know having drinks
with the enemies let's just say and
maybe that's you know telling some
secrets and
as we know this is spring break for
cotton for NFL coaches and this is what
they do they hang by the bars they drink
they look at football they watch players
they drink some more they hang yeah
there's no sodium pentathol but there's
plenty of truth sir me there is and
that's where I think between
cost-effective and I think coaches and
GM's realizing that maybe it's not the
best thing for their organization I
think you're gonna continue continue to
see this trend I think we'll see a
handful of teams do it next year I think
at a certain point we will see teams use
that as a way to push back against this
effort to make the event larger and
larger and larger it's going to LA at
some point yeah it seems like workouts
are staying in primetime and they're
gonna fill that stage I like it people I
know but but I think that especially
once it goes to LA and everything is and
I'll pack together inconvenient and you
can like you know the ride over here
today for us was three minutes right LA
Ingleby three minutes so I don't know
and and the coaches are gonna be dealing
with yeah moaning about a revolt against
it so we're gonna stop going or we're
gonna stop sending as many people we're
gonna top we're gonna stop treating it
like the big deal that you're treating
it because we present the fact that the
attorneys are just circus right right
and that's what I had a GM tell me last
week when we we started talking about
the idea that they moved the workouts to
primetime and it screws up the schedule
they're opening Pandora's box you're
familiar with Pandora I do yeah it's
full of Pandora yeah at least you've
gotten the gender right well he can be
taught it is a she not a he but they're
opening Pandora's box as it relates to
trying to make this like the draft
because it's not the draft it's a
different event altogether
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports